JUSTIN JACKSON: "And the
Lord God called to the human
and said to him, 'Where
are you?'" What a beautiful
question, where are you?
And this is this existential
question for Adam now.
"Now the serpent
was most cunning
of all the beasts of the field
that the Lord God had made.
And he said to the woman,
'Though God said you shall not
eat from any tree of the
garden--' And the woman said
to the serpent, 'From the fruit
of the gardens trees we may
eat, but from the fruit
of the tree in the midst
of the garden, God has said 'You
shall not eat from it and you
shall not touch
it, lest you die.'
And the serpent
said to the woman,
'You shall not be doomed to die.
For God knows that on
the day you eat of it,
your eyes will be open.
And you will become as gods,
knowing good and evil.'
And the woman saw that the
tree was good for eating
and that it was
lust to the eyes.
And the tree was
lovely to look at.
And she took of
its fruit and ate.
And she also gave to
her man, and he ate.
And the eyes of the
two were opened,
and they knew they
were naked, and they
sewed fig leaves and made
themselves loincloths."
So let's just begin, first and
foremost, with the narrative
that we know all so well.
God gave Adam and
Eve a commandment.
They're prideful
desire to become
like gods is precisely
what allows them
to be tempted by the serpent.
And giving in to
this temptation,
they break a commandment
of God and thus
break their relationship
with the divine.
And as a consequence of
this, God, of course,
escorts them out of the garden.
And in some ways, we read
this as just response.
They had a commandment.
They broke the commandment.
They broke their
relationship with the divine.
And now, of course, they
have to live their life quite
differently now in this world.
"And they heard the sound
of the Lord God walking
about in the garden
in the evening breeze,
and the human and his
woman hid from the Lord God
in the midst of the
trees of the garden.
And the Lord God called to
the human and said to him,
'Where are you?'" What
a beautiful question.
Where are you?
And this is this existential
question for Adam now.
Just think about it.
He's hiding from his creator,
the one to whom he was
called to be in relationship.
He's now hiding from him.
"And he said, 'I heard your
sound in the garden and I was
afraid, for I was
naked, and I hid.'
And he said, 'Who told
you that you were naked?'
From the tree I commanded you
not to eat have you eaten!'" In
some ways, we can look back
to the various traditions,
both Rabbinic and Christian, and
they understand these questions
in a very precise way.
And this is God calling
Adam and Eve to repentance.
Look, the narrative
here-- let's just boil it
down to something simple.
There are commandments.
In this case,
there's one command.
One is to keep it, to stay in
relationship to the divine.
Follow the commandments.
If you don't follow
the commandments,
simply turn back to God
and say, I'm sorry God.
I did not follow
the commandments.
And then, of course,
you'll be asked
to follow the commandments.
It's a really simple
narrative that we
can see all throughout
these biblical texts.
And in particular,
here, "And he said, 'Who
told you that you were naked?
From the tree that I commanded
you not to eat you have eaten!'
And the human said--
here's his chance to repent--
'The woman whom you gave by
me, she gave me from the tree,
and I ate.'"
Now, all of a sudden, I think
we can see what's going on here.
If we're talking
about the intersection
of the divine and human
relationship, combined
with the human and
human relationship,
then what we see here is a
rupture of both simultaneously.
Adam, who has his life,
who names himself only
after this woman
who's taken from him
his very self, who gives
him a sense of personhood.
This sustainer beside him,
notice what he's willing to do.
He cuts her off.
And his language is perfect.
"The woman whom you gave to me."
In a double sense, he's
passing off this responsibility
to his wife and now to God.
So we see a
simultaneous disruption
of the divine relationship and
the human relationship here.
"And the Lord God
said to the woman,
'What is this you have done?'
And the woman said, 'The
serpent beguiled me,
and I ate.'" Notice
what she does here,
passes blame off to the serpent.
She doesn't even mention that
she gave the fruit to Adam
and he ate.
She doesn't even mention this.
So let's just go
back a little bit
and ask a couple of questions.
What is the state that
Adam and Eve are now
in with regards to their
relationship to the divine?
They stand in front of
him, naked and ashamed.
Whereas before, they were
naked and did not know it.
Because they've had
this double knowledge,
they've transgressed
and are conscious
of their transgression.
Now, their state
is one of shame.
And now, you can
really start thinking
about justice and mercy.
Would not justice
be God saying, I
told you not to eat of the tree
of knowledge and good and evil?
And yet you've done so.
And so now, you shall just have
the fruit of your transgression
here.
You shall now live
in this shame which
you've brought upon yourself.
And so when we look here,
"Now that the human has become
like one of us,
knowing good and evil,
let us not let them take
from the tree of life
and live forever."
God is not afraid of a
rivalry of his creation.
He's not afraid that
they've become gods.
He set everything in place so
that they could become godlike.
I mean, really, as a God who
created mud, he's created soil,
and he's turned them into gods.
Is a God who has that sort of
enormous power really going
to rival these godlike creatures
that he's created from mud?
Rather, it was a graciousness on
the part of the divine to say,
I am going to create creatures
who, with their will,
can live and participate
in the divine life.
And whereas at one point
they had one commandment
to do so, well, now, OK, we
have the original transgression.
Now, they have 1,613
commandments to do so.
And those 1,613 commandments
should be seen as a joy,
as another opportunity to
exist in that divine and human
relationship.
So then what we see here
then, cutting them off
from the Garden of Eden,
to put the cherubim
at that tree of life, to cut
them off from immortality,
to become these godlike
creatures living
in shame in perpetuity,
rather than an act of justice,
it is an act of mercy.
Rather than letting them,
by their own free will,
create a hell out of a paradise
which he's given to them,
he has cut them off
from that and is
going to now allow them to exist
in relationship to the divine
in a different manner.
And the rest of
Genesis is going to be
a teasing out, and
through the whole Tanakh--
through the whole Hebrew Bible--
is going to be a
question of what
does that new
relationship look like?
SPEAKER: Thank you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our highlight series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.